what advice would you give to people
that are in their 30s are entering their
30s about how to operate in life
I think it's really situational I don't
think there's a user's manual I think
there's some best practices and I don't
think it's that much different than in
your 20s
um the first is very Primal I think
every person in their 20s and 30s should
lift heavy weights and run long
distances in their brain and in the gym
push yourself really hard when you're in
your 20s and 30s you don't even realize
how old are you 34. okay so like you
look like a beast in in 20 years you're
just going to look back on how strong
you were and just marvel at it and
you're going to wish as strong as you
were that you even push yourself harder
I rode crew it was such a valuable part
of my life I did at the age of 19. and I
remember in the midst of a race it's a 2
000 meter race
and I remember not being able to feel my
legs starting to black out and having to
concentrate on not blacking out from
exhaustion my and the the oxygen or the
air going down my esophagus was on fire
tastes like blood and metal in your
throat yeah and that was at 800 meters
and you'd go 2 000. and that ability
just when you think just when you think
you can't take any more
that means you're about a third of the
way to your limits as as a as a human as
a species learning that as a young man
or woman is a blessing because what it
means is you have the confidence that
when when things are hard physically
emotionally mentally you realize oh my
God I could take so much more and still
be fine and when I worked my first job
was a Morton Stanley Investment Bank and
I was undereducated relative to my peer
group not because I didn't go to a great
school I went to UCLA but I spent the
majority of my five years there making
bongs out of household items and
watching Planet of the Apes so I wasn't
as skilled as my peer group so I decided
every Tuesday morning I was going to
come into work
and I wasn't going to leave till
Wednesday night
and I'm like I can do that I'm
physically really strong I'm mentally
really strong
and it sent a signal to the rest of the
organization that I came to play
develop that kind of grit and strength
emotionally physically and
intellectually in your 20s and 30s
you're capable of it you're just going
to look back on that errand like just
marvel it out out of [ __ ] control
strong you are both mentally and
physically
2. get to a city if you can and that
sounds very practical or wrote but you'd
rather be good in a big city than great
in a small City before you collect dogs
and kids
you know being in a city is like playing
tennis with Roger Federer or Nadal when
you play with people much better than
you your game gets much better you're
playing against the best when you're in
a city
uh
find create as many opportunities to
find a mate now what do I mean by that
get out as often as possible accept
invitations force yourself to go out
force yourself to meet strangers develop
the skills
uh start whenever you're waiting in line
at Starbucks talk to the person in front
of you talk to the person behind you
develop the skills to begin opening and
establishing relationships and it's
uncomfortable and it means getting used
to rejection
and by the way the only thing I can
guarantee you in life
is rejection and the only thing I
guarantee a lot of if you want to be
successful is a [ __ ] ton of rejection
being an entrepreneur just means you're
willing to take out a big spoon and eat
[ __ ] all the time talking people into
working for you talking clients into to
to to engaging you talking investors
into investing and having 90 plus
percent of them saying no and the same
is true with successful mating the most
important decision you'll make in your
20s and 30s is where you live where you
work what industry you're going to it's
who you decide to partner with
specifically who you decide to
ultimately have kids with and I have
close friends who are monstrously
successful by every external metric and
they don't have great lives because they
don't have real Partners in their
spouses and I have other friends who
struggle economically and it's hard
but everything's a little easier for
them because they have a real partner
and the way you punch above your weight
class and find a great mate uh you know
emotionally intellectually from a value
standpoint sexually is you give yourself
as many opportunities as possible and my
story is I met uh my partner who I had
kids with at the Raleigh Hotel at the
pool at the Raleigh Hotel in South Beach
about 17 years ago it was the middle of
the day and I walked in and I think it's
important to do this I walked in and I
saw someone I was really attracted to
and I said I'm going to talk to this
person before I leave and I promise
myself and I went up
in the full light of midday sun when she
was sitting with another guy and another
girl and opened and without the aid of
alcohol that is not easy that is not
easy and fast forward my oldest son's
middle name is Raleigh if you nothing
wonderful is going to happen to you
unless you take an uncomfortable risk so
get good at taking them get good at
sending blind emails to LinkedIn
contacts to ask them for coffee to see
if they'll talk to you about that
industry
reach out to people tell them you admire
them try and become friends with them
you know you're you're an interesting
guy I was just thinking to myself I'd
love to know this guy does he live in
London he just seems very cool get
comfortable taking those sorts of risks
get comfortable with rejection nothing
wonderful will happen to you unless you
take an uncomfortable risk the most
important thing you can find in your
life in your 20s and 30s is something
that you're good at so that you can
start
building a base around Economic Security
but the the real key is to find a great
partner and that is going to be a
function of liquidity how many great
Partners potential great Partners you
approach and unfortunately
the far left of which I'm apart as tree
as as counseled men that if you start
talking to a woman at work and you
express any sort of Interest it means
you're toxic no it doesn't if you don't
know the difference between expressing
interest and having coffee with someone
and harassing them you've got much
bigger problems a third of relationships
begin at work I'm not suggesting anyone
should ever abuse their power I'm I'm
not suggesting you shouldn't be very
careful that you're ever leveraging
power making anyone uncomfortable but
for God's sakes go up and talk to
strangers there's nothing wrong with
that and if you approach a strange woman
and and try and express get a
conversation going and she's not
interested you're both going to be fine
you're both gonna be fine and what I see
as a generation of men who don't take
care of themselves physically and become
so isolated that the idea of talking to
a strange woman is so alien and alien
and uncomfortable to them they just
rather stay home and do something else
and I don't want to stereotype all
introverts is is leading to bad places
that's not true at all but the majority
of men you talk to they want to be
financially successful and they want to
have a great partner at some point and
that is a function of of your
willingness to put yourself in
uncomfortable situation so anyways get
mentally and physically strong take
economic responsibility for your
household get out of the house as much
as possible try and find things where
you're building something in the agency
of others I don't care every day you
should be be around strangers every day
like if it's work I don't know if it's
church I don't care if it's non-profit a
softball league the gym classes whatever
it is you need to be around a massive
number of strangers and finding reasons
to have bump off of them and find
economic and personal and platonic
opportunities as often as possible we
are a social species to get to a city
get around a lot of people get out there
every day start making money and become
really strong you should be able to walk
into any room in your at your age and
think if [ __ ] got real I can kill and
eat everybody or outrun them one or the
other one or the other now I'm at the
point where I can do neither I'm not
strong and my knees are going but
anyways at your age it should be one or
both you could pay someone to kill
everybody or coming there you go that
would be awesome there you go yeah
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]